bonjour merci d'être avec nous paula
vous vous trouvez non loin de la
frontière entre israël et gaza quelle
est la situation sur place de votre côté
la situation est très tendue
vous pouvez peut-être voir derrière moi
de la fumée à l'horizon ces gaz a nommé
pouvons pas nous approchons est
davantage du côté israélien des soldats
l'armée israélienne
juste derrière moi et ils les ont bouclé
la zone déclarée zone militaire ne
pouvons donc pas nous approcher
davantage alors que je vous attendais
toute une série de roquettes ont été
tirées depuis gaza est l'une d'entre
elles a explosé juste au dessus de l ue
elle a été interceptée par le dos me
réfère est alors que nous nous
déplacions dans cette zone devient
régulièrement arrêter la voiture
précipitamment nous réfugier dans le
caniveau
afin d'essayer de les protéger de ces
barrages la situation est extrêmement
tendue et je peux entendre beaucoup de
disques à la distance ce sont nos
frappes israéliennes sur gaza
comme je vous le dis donc
des roquettes sont tirées en terminant
il s'est depuis gaza vers israël
là où je me trouve paul à l'armée
israélienne a frappé aujourd'hui
l'immeuble abritant les bureaux des
médias jazeera et associatives presse
l'agencé ap qui s'est dit choqué et
horrifié par cette frappe israélienne
vous pouvez nous dire ce qui s'est passé
précisément est ce qu'il ya eu des
victimes est ce que les locaux étaient
vides
racontez-nous étaient en vie
heureusement haineux aucune victime car
l'armée israélienne a donné un préavis
d'une résidence du bâtiment savants les
détruire
selon l'armée malienne ce bâtiment
abrite uli abriter leur sérieux hamas
pose également comme vous n'avez du
souci à tous et qui sera d'essayer de
médias plus tôt dans la semaine
israël a détruit un bâtiment à environ
21,15 euros de presse le trouver mais il
sait elle a défendu sa tête des dix ans
à ma place et élégamment ses opérations
militaires dans des bâtiments où sont
des civils et des organes de presse afin
de se défendre et de dire qu'israël y at
il des civils alors qu'en fait hamas
utilisent des civils comme le
propriétaire du bâtiment a pu
s'entretenir avec les israéliens avant
cela la destruction complétion et du
bâtiment qui est réduit à 90 aux
propriétés a demandé si l'armée pouvait
donner un peu plus de temps aux
journalistes afin de récupérer leurs
équipements mais cela a été refusé
j'ai eu un contact avec les collèges
notamment à gaza et il manque cet
équipement il manque de cette élite des
journalistes à gaza ont de plus en plus
de difficultés à trouver l'équipement
défenseur afin de diffuser ce qui arrive
sur place on dénombre plus d'une
centaine de morts à gaza et près de 1000
blessés depuis le début de la semaine
qu'elle est laide qui est apportée aux
personnes blessés ou déplacés font
également comptabilisé md 250 bâtiments
et les enceintes été détruits donc
effectivement beaucoup de serre seraient
faits pour la mairie et beaucoup d'entre
eux se soumirent tourné vers l'agencé
par les nations unies notamment ceux
dans le nord de la bande de gaza d'après
les nations unies oui j'ai donc du mal
gérer la situation exemple du mal à
contacter toutes les personnes touchées
et elle manque de place l'élu a
également déclaré avoir beaucoup de mal
avec la situation humanitaire à
s'assurer que tous les civils
tous les gazaouis sont en sécurité et
que les survivants reçoivent les soins
dont ils ont besoin
alors voilà vous avez pu vous rendre à
ramat gan en banlieue de tel-aviv vide
qui est particulièrement visée par des
tirs quelle est la réalité de la
situation auprès de tel aviv d'ailleurs
je me trouvais et je ne suis pas si
c'est une chance
j'en ai trop fait je les défends depuis
trois d'entre elles sont tombées à ramat
gan ya juste la très proche de tel à 2,8
et celle est qui a causé le plus de
dégâts
lequel est un jouet rue a détruit les
voitures de cette rue et les les
vitrines de toutes parts et que les
fenêtres
un homme a été blessé et il est mort
dans l'ambulance
le bilan tout cas sera là également j'ai
parlé avec lui au moins est des coûts
disent qu'ils ont peur mais qu'ils ont
l'impression qu'en fin de compte elle
est inévitable
ce sera à mars si les têtes il évita
tissera et amar se retrouve dans ce
conflit qui se préparait depuis
longtemps frontières comme un centre
l'israël et certains de l'autre côté de
la frontière la situation est
extrêmement tendue poids la crs qu'on
peut espérer une désescalade détention
dans les jours à venir
ou pas selon vous des salines de mon
travail dans cette région c'est qu'on
n'est que jamais rien que dire si nous
évoque sur le terrain une désescalade
potentielle des efforts pour donner
notamment histoire de diplomates
égyptiens qui tentent de préparer un
cessez le feu entre hamas qu'israël
pourrait y avoir une désescalade à
partir de demain dimanche il sera
expirée essayer de nettoyer guerlain à
l'occasion c'est à dire je détruis vers
autant de plateformes de lancement de
roquettes
autant en milieu occupé par le hamas que
possible vendredi cinq ans d'attenté
lancement à gaza ont été détruites et
donc effectivement on commence à parler
de désescalade dans les journées à venir
mais c'est difficile à dire
tout ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
la situation sur le terrain alors nous
on retrouve un samedi après-midi en
général dans la rue afin de passer au
lion comédie agréable et bien et tous
les magasins sont fermés il n'y a
personne dans les rues sinon à part la
police les tanks et les journalistes les
gens restent chez eux ils ont peur paul
ailleurs merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions merci pour cet éclairage je
rappelle que vous êtes à la frontière
entre gaza et israël